Evan from Norway has asked me
to do another u substitution
problem, and I like these
because it gets my momentum
going for doing other things
that maybe take a little
bit more preparation.
And the problem he sent me--
and I hope I pronounced his
name right-- was the indefinite
integral of sin of x over
the cosine of x squared dx.
This it also be written as-- he
wrote it in email, so I don't
know how he exactly saw it, but
it can also be written as sin
of x over cosine squared of x.
Sometimes it's
written like that.
Either way, I like looking
at this a bit better.
It's a little bit
less ambiguous.
But in general you know to do u
substitution, or integration by
substitution when you see
something and you see its
derivative sitting there.
Right.
You're like wow, this cosine of
x was just an x, or if it was
just a u, this would be a
really easy integral to do.
We know how to do
this integral.
Let me do it on the side.
This integral would be easy.
1 over x squared dx.
We know how to do that.
That would just be the
antiderivative of x squared.
This is the same thing as the
antiderivative of x to the
minus 2 dx, and we know how to
take the antiderivative
of something like that.
You increase the exponent by
1 and then you multiply by
what your new exponent is.
So it would be minus
x-- I'm sorry.
You increase your exponent by
1, and then you divide by
whatever your new exponent is.
So you would,
[? let me do the, ?]
increasing the exponent x to
the minus 2, you'd increase
the exponent, you'd
get x to the minus 1.
And then when you divide this
by minus 1 you get this minus
out front, and then of course
you'd have the plus c.
If you don't believe it
take the derivative.
Negative 1 times minus 1.
That's a positive.
And then you'd decrease
the exponent by 1, you
get x to the minus 2.
So if we could get it in
a form that looks like
this, we'd be all set.
And you kind of do
see a pattern.
Where this x is you have a
cosine there, and then we have
cosines derivative there.
So that's the big clue that we
should be using u substitution.
So let's do that.
And what we're going to do is
we're going to substitute
u for cosine of x.
So if we say u is equal to
cosine of x, and let's take
the derivative of u
with respect to x.
So du/dx is equal to what?
What's the derivative of
cosine of x? it's not
quite sin of x, right?
It's minus sin of x.
And then we can multiply both
sides by dx, and you get du is
equal to minus sin of x dx.
I just multiplied
both sides by dx.
And then up here we
have sin of x dx.
We don't have minus
sin of x dx.
There we have sin of x dx.
We could have rewritten this
top integral, we could have
rewritten it like this.
Sin of x dx.
All of that over
cosine of x squared.
So if we want to substitute for
this, here we have a minus.
Let's multiply both sides of
this by a negative 1, and you
get minus du is equal
to sin of x dx.
And let's see.
So let's rewrite this
original problem.
Now I know I'm running
out of space.
Let me rewrite it.
So we know that u is equal to
cosine of x, so let's do that.
So now this integral becomes--
and the denominator, instead of
cosine of x squared,
u is cosine of x.
That's u, right?
We made that definition.
So that's over u squared.
Cosine of x becomes u.
And then sin of x dx right up
there, what is that equal to?
Well we just solved
for it here.
That's equal to minus du.
Sin of x dx is
equal to minus du.
So that we can replace
with this, minus du.
And then of course this has
the exact same form as
this thing right here.
You could rewrite this,
this is equal to let's say
minus 1 over u squared du.
I'm just writing it a
bunch of different ways.
Whatever is easier for
you to conceptualize.
The same thing as minus
u to the minus 2 du.
And then here we do the same
thing we did up here, although
now we have a minus out front,
that actually makes it
a little bit cleaner.
To take the antiderivative, we
raise u-- it was to the minus 2
power, let's raise it to 1
power higher than that-- so
minus 2 plus 1 is minus 1.
So it's u to the minus 1 power,
and then you want to divide by
minus 1, and I'll do
it explicitly here.
Minus one.
And then you had this negative
that was sitting out there
before, so that negative is
still going to be there.
And of course you're
going to have a plus c.
You can view this as a negative
1 or, this negative divided
by a negative, they're
going to cancel out.
And so you're just left with u
to the minus 1 plus c, or 1
over u plus c is the
antiderivative-- oh sorry,
we're not done yet.
That's just the
antiderivative of this.
And now we have our
substitution to deal with.
What was our substitution
that we started with?
u is equal to cosine of x.
So if u is equal to cosine of
x, this thing is equal to 1
over cosine of x plus c is
equal to the antiderivative of
our original problem, which was
sin of x over cosine
of x squared dx.
There you go.
See you in the next video.